BEN POIESZ: Hi, everybody.
I'm Ben Poiesz.
I'm the product manager
for the Android Framework.
I wanted to thank everybody for
sticking through on a Friday
on comissions.
So we're going to
talk about some
of the best practices,
some of the new stuff
that's [INAUDIBLE] that was
talked about in the keynote.
And getting some
into the specifics,
into the nitty-gritty.
But first, let's start
with where we are
and where we're going to.
And so today, we
have a situation
where users have awareness of
what permissions are, but they
don't have the level of control
that we want them to have.
We also have an
issue for developers
that are updating their
applications-- are
making really tough
decisions about,
do I add this permission?
Do I want to get hit
on my uptake rate?
And so we're looking
to solve that as well.
And the last one is it's install
friction that we get as well.
When you're clicking
the Install button,
it doesn't actually install.
You get a prompt saying, hey,
here's a bunch of information
that you probably don't
want to read right now.
But we're going
to show it to you
and you're going to
hit this Accept button
and then we'll download
and install it for you.
And so the question that
we asked ourselves a lot
over the last years and months
of looking at this problem is,
how do we make it better?
And so here's what
we've come up with.
And so the idea is we want
to make this much simpler
for users to understand.
And the idea being,
if it's simpler
and it's focused on the
things that users care about,
then they're more empowered
and in even more control.
The other part
is, we want to put
in the control of the
developers that you can request
these permissions at
runtime, at the point in time
it makes sense for
you to provide context
to the user about
why you want it.
And the last one is to also
improve some information
to the user about auditing.
And the idea for
auditing-- we'll
talk about it a little
bit-- is that, if you
have an understanding of what
applications do what-- what's
normal, what's
different-- users can also
make informed decisions
about odd behaviors.
And so here's the list of
permissions in their entirety.
The keynote didn't have
the full set, by the way.
So we start off with
Location and Camera, which
are fairly straightforward.
The next is Microphone--
so Microphone
is separate from Camera.
So Camera controls
photos and video.
So if you're doing video
with audio recording,
you'll want to request both.
Phone includes phone
state and dialing.
So this is if your application
is performing functionality
that makes calls often or
is trying to manage calling,
you'll want to request this.
These are the groups, by
the way, just as a moment.
I forgot to mention.
There's still the individual
permissions that you request.
These are just the
high-level groups.
And we'll talk about load
distinction a little bit later.
For SMS, as well as for
controlling and reading
SMS in your application.
And then the next two are pretty
straightforward-- Contacts
and Calendar, each
being separate for
read and write access to
your Contacts and Calendar,
respectively.
And the last one
is about Sensors.
And Sensors is a tricky one.
Users don't really understand
this one quite yet really well.
It's around heart rate
monitors, body information,
and body sensors.
And this is a new space
that's evolving pretty quickly
and we wanted to
make sure it was
accounted for in the
new permissions model.
So what this gives us then is
now we're asking at runtime--
we don't need to have
a prompt when you're
clicking the Install button.
Installing now does
the thing that it
says it does-- it installs.
This also means updates can
now happen automatically.
And so when you're getting
your applications pushed,
they include new permissions.
Those permissions aren't
granted on install anymore--
they're granted at runtime.
So those APK binaries can
all get pushed right away.
And so what happens
at runtime, then?
When do you ask?
How do you ask?
And so this is where
you're able to ask
the user, at a point in
time that makes sense
in your application, what
you want to have access to.
In this case, here we have
Hangouts asking for the ability
to manage phone calls.
These are unique for each user.
So no longer is this
applied across all users
on your device.
It's individual to
each Android user.
And there's a special note here.
We'll talk about this in the
Best Practices a little bit
later-- it's about
Don't ask again.
On the first request,
the users are not
going to see this checkbox.
So you'll just have the
question and Allow/Deny.
Allow/Deny in this
world is a long time.
It's not a one-time response,
it's a forever answer.
But developers are able to ask
again in the case of saying no.
And the trick is, on
the second request
and subsequent requests--
after the user's
said no, they have a shush
button where they can say,
don't ask me again.
And this is a clear indicator
to us at the OS level
that the user and the developer
aren't really on the same page
about what's being
asked of them.
And what will happen
is feature request
by the developer goes
straight to the no answer.
We don't prompt UI, we won't
bother the user with it
because they've
indicated this flag.
And so the idea is, the first
request, there's no penalty.
So feel free to use it.
On the subsequent requests,
make sure you and the user
are on the same page about
what you're talking about.
And we'll cover this again
in the Best Practices,
because it's a big point
that we want to make great
about the experience.
The other part is
in System Settings.
And so in System
Settings now, not only
can users today see
all the permissions,
but they see the new groups.
And they have nice little toggle
switches next to these groups.
And so every application
on your device,
users are now going to be
able to toggle these switches.
This means that they're
able to look at something,
they can turn things
on that are off,
turn things off that are on.
There's no penalty with
them turning stuff off.
So if a user says
no to something,
you have the ability
to ask again.
They'll then have that prompt,
as I mentioned before, to say
don't ask again if
it's been too often.
And the idea is this
is always available,
any time, all applications.
And that's a big distinction
in really empowering users
to use these controls.
We also have a vertical view.
And so on the vertical
view, I can look at Camera.
And this is the auditing
I was mentioning before,
in that a user can look
at every application.
Who's using Camera?
And I can say, oh,
these ones make sense.
I use these.
Ooh, these ones don't
make so much sense to me.
Let me turn those off.
And if the application, then,
is running and they can say,
you turned off Camera for me,
but I do really cool things
with the camera.
You should turn this back on.
And you're like, oh, you do do
cool things with the camera.
I'll turn you back on.
And so that's going to
lead into-- what do you do?
We have this world.
And so what are the best
practices for the developer?
And the trick is,
for many folks,
you feel a little nervous,
I guess, as a developer.
And you start feeling,
what's the user going to do?
What's going to happen?
I'm not really sure.
And so these best practices
we're going to talk about,
it's not guesswork.
This should really
be predictable.
Users should understand
why you're asking.
And when users understand
what your value proposition is
and you're explaining
yourself clearly,
they're going to say
yes most the time.
And so that's the idea.
And so let's talk about
some of those practices.
And all these
practices, by the way--
you don't have to do them all.
This is just covering
a variety of things
that make sense,
depending on situations
and how you structure
your application.
And so the idea here
is, on a warm welcome,
you're pitching a user on what
it is your application does.
You'll see this in
Google Now as an example.
It's an application that asks
for a lot of permissions.
It's very integrated
with your experience.
And so they're making very
clear in the Google Now
application what their value
proposition is to the user.
And when that's made,
it makes sense when
you ask for things upfront.
And so in the case here, we
have Hangouts asking for SMS.
And it also will ask for
other permissions as well.
But the idea is, when you're
asking it upfront and it makes
sense where your application--
Hangouts, [? in this case ?]--
manages and sends SMS
and messaging in general.
There's no real dissonance
between the application, what
its use case is, what
the user expectation is
for this application,
and what it's asking for.
If it was coming up and asking
for Calendar out of the blue,
I'd probably scratch my head
in wondering what's going on.
And this is where we don't
need to provide that education
for these initial requests,
where it makes sense
based upon your functionality
of your application.
For things where it's a
bit more edgy or maybe
you don't need to ask
for it upfront and it's
a particular feature--
and here we're looking
at Keep for the first time.
And you have an option
here for recording,
where I can record
a Voice Note and it
will transcribe the Voice Note.
And this is a great
case where, now it
makes sense for me, the
user, in this case clicking
the record button.
And keep asking me if
they can record audio.
And I'm like, of course you can.
And this is the
structure that we
want to have where you and
the user are on the same page.
This also avoids cases
of double prompting
which we've seen
in other platforms
where we have similar
runtime models.
And we really want to
avoid a double prompt.
And the idea is, if you're
asking the first time,
there's no penalty
on the first request.
Go ahead and ask.
If they say no,
be cool about it.
And then figure out what's
the best way to ask again
at some future point in time.
Maybe you wait
until the next time
they hit the record button.
And say, hey, you're
hitting the record button.
Do you want to
record a Voice Note?
I'm like, I do.
So that's the idea for it.
Also, you don't always
need permissions.
And so it's on the
highlight that we
have a variety of system
intents in the platform.
So these are for Camera,
for making phone calls,
for getting contacts.
These don't require permissions.
The reason they don't
require permissions
is because the user is the
one pressing the button,
selecting the contact,
taking the photo.
And so your application is
freely able to invoke these.
So when this is an
option, highly preferable
to use these approaches because
it doesn't require any upfront
ask.
And it lets the user
know, the developer
is caring about my
ability to set actions.
The next one is, what
if your application
needs a variety of
things to do its job?
And as an example
here using Hangouts,
Hangouts is a messaging client.
So it would need things like
Contacts Phone permission,
and SMS.
And so we have an option for
allowing a developer to request
multiple permissions in one go.
Now we do, as you're seeing
in the animation here,
present them one at
a time to the user.
So the idea is you
want to be balanced
in how you're presenting
these multiple requests.
If they make sense and
they're relatively narrow,
you'll get a quick
user understanding
and a quick response.
If you try to blast
everything upfront,
you'll probably get
some nos in there.
And so the idea is
to do the things that
make sense for the user.
The next one is, give
a response immediately.
If you ask for something,
think of it as an exchange.
I'm going to give
you some of my data.
What are you going to do for me?
And so, in the case of Earth,
it's a really obvious one.
Zoom in to where
you currently are.
But there's lots of
other ones that are
particular to your application.
But always think
about, what's my ROI?
When the user's
thinking about it,
what am I going
to give them back?
In cases where you
ask for something
and it's not immediately
understandable to the user
as to why you
asked, they're going
to wonder why they turned it on
and they might go turn it off.
The next thing is to look at
the material design documents
that we have online and the
guidelines that are online.
Empty state is a really
useful one to take a look at.
And think about how, if
you have a function--
maybe you have a search
view and your search
view depends on
certain permissions
to populate its data.
How do you present
an empty state?
Or how do you present
the suggestion of,
this is better if you had this?
So those kind of
structures enable
users to understand your value
proposition better and get
them to say yes to these
different permissions
that you're looking to have.
And so let's get into
that little bit, more
of the nitty-gritty
that I mentioned before.
And this is that,
on an M, we're not
requiring all applications
support runtime permissions.
However, if you're
on an M device
and you're compiling against the
MSDK with a target of API 23,
you're going to be in
the permissions model.
And so what this
is going to mean
is you need to write
some really complex code.
I know, it's pretty rough.
But what we have here are just
highlighting the two main APIs
that you're going to
be wanting to look at.
One is checkSelfpermissions
and the other one
is requestPermissions.
And so the idea is
you'll check, hey,
what permissions do I have
available to me right now?
If you're missing
anything that you need,
you can request
those permissions
and then continue on
with your functionality,
assuming it's gone well.
And that's the structure of it.
You don't have to worry
about callbacks at runtime,
where you're wondering, what if
I'm the middle of an operation
and the user turns off
permission for me in settings?
Not to worry, we
kill your process.
So the good part about
that, though-- as
opposed to being
killed-- is it's
the same method as if
you're in low memory.
So there's not a special
mode or handling to do here.
It's treated the same as
a low memory condition.
But what happens then is,
when you're booting up
in your application
sequence, just
check your permissions values.
If you always do
that on your startup
and you check your results and
cache them, you'll be fine.
They won't change on you.
They'll only change
when you ask and they'll
go in the positive sense.
They'll never go away on you.
When they go away, you'll get
killed and brought back up.
So you don't have to worry
about runtime handling.
The last one is you might
be furiously thinking,
where do I use permissions?
What are my APIs that
are using permissions?
How am I going to check them?
And so this is what we've
added in Android Studio.
And if you were in that talk,
they made mention of it,
so I'll cross-reference
their mentioning of my stuff
with their stuff.
They added annotations.
And annotations does is it
introduces new Lint warnings
and errors so that when
you're using Studio
and you add a
function that needs
a permission-- in
the case here, I'm
using Location Manager to get
the location of the user-- I'll
get a warning
saying, hey, your APK
doesn't actually declare
the necessary permission
to use this function.
Also, we'll notice is, if
you don't have a check,
you're not guarding
this particular call.
And we give you a
template-ized version
where we can populate in
[? a little ?] boilerplate
piece of code to help
you do a request.
And so that way everything is
about our M Apps on the MSDK.
And so you may be wondering
what about all these L
Apps and pre-M applications
that are all out there.
How are they going to
behave in this model?
Because if you
notice before, I said
a lot of alls and every about
these different controls.
And so one thing that's
going to be different
is, at install
time, you're still
going to see the
current dialogue.
So, because applications
that are pre-M
don't understand what it means
to have their permissions taken
away or what it means to
start off with nothing,
we're going to treat them
a little bit differently.
So we're still going
to prompt the user.
There'll be a call-out of
this application as our legacy
app in play.
And on install, you'll be
granted your permissions
pretty much the same as today.
Also Updates will
now be blocking
as they are today, instead
of the smooth ones that I
spoke about before.
The next thing, though,
is in the Settings panel.
Users will still
be able to turn off
settings on your applications.
Now this isn't going to cause
security exceptions for you.
That would happen
in the new model
if your app is on the MSDK.
But in this case,
what we do is we
identify that this application
is compiled on an older SDK
and we begin feeding
it empty state data.
And so if we were to ask,
well, what's the location?
I would say, the
location's not available.
It's a valid error state.
You'd say, are
there any contacts?
No, there aren't any contacts.
When you want to save a contact,
we're like, yeah, we saved it.
No, we didn't save it.
And so when you check it, you
would find that it'd be empty.
So this can make some wonky
behaviors in applications.
Users will get a Warning.
So when they're
turning something off,
we just don't want to let the
user flip it off and assume
it's going to be OK.
Or if the app starts
behaving strangely.
So we do have this
Warning to make
sure users are aware this
is a control that they have.
But also they may need to
come back and turn it back on
or maybe they have to get
rid of the application
if they end up in
an odd behavior.
An example might
be-- I do Hangouts
and I see it's using
Camera and it's maybe not
apparently obvious to
me that it needs Camera.
I turn it off.
A few weeks later, I
have a Hangout call
and the video's not working.
And you're like, why?
And they might not go, oh,
because I turned off the Camera
and I have to go
back and flip it on.
Hopefully, Hangouts
won't have that problem
because they'll be a
modern application.
But just for the example.
The last one is, when things
are turned off in a pre-M app,
because it's not on the MSDK,
it can't request permissions.
And this is where we're really
looking for app developers
to adopt the model as
quickly as you can.
And this really only
makes good sense
for users when we
only have one model,
where everything is runtime.
As opposed to the
hybrid that we're
going to have in the beginning.
I've used the metaphor
that this is switching
from the left side of the road
to the right side of the road.
Going to be a little
messy in the beginning.
And so we really want to
make sure that applications
are moving over.
We've tried to give
a lot of incentives
for developers to move over,
especially around being
able to ask multiple
times, around being
able to ask in bulk, and making
updates more seamless when
you're adding new permissions.
And so with that,
I'm ending early.
So if you're planning
to head home,
you'll be able to go home early.
But if not, lots of
Q&A. I'm assuming
there's lots of questions here.
So I'll stay here for the next--
I think we have 24 minutes.
And if you guys have questions,
feel free to go to the mic
up ahead and try this out.
Also, there's a full code
example on the website.
We have code snippets
of all this stuff.
There's a big write-up about
permissions, about the best
practices, about the behaviors.
There will be more coming out
on best practices and behaviors
and UI guidelines, so please
check developer.android.com
for new updates.
And with that, thank you.
Go for it.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
It's cool to have granular
permissions finally.
It reminds me of iOS sometimes.
Speaking of which,
is there a way
to supply an
explanation of why we
are asking for the permission?
BEN POIESZ: Not right now.
We are looking at
the options of a note
from the developer in the
dialogue that I was showing.
There's a little
bit of trickiness
of when the OS is stating
a piece of information
on the path of an
application developer.
Is that a false premise,
is it legitimate?
And so we're trying
to deal with,
what's the right way
to present the balance?
Like, this is a statement
from the developer
while it's in system UI.
If you do you feel like you
need to explain to the user
why you want something, I
highly recommend their approach
that we mentioned
before-- ask first.
There's no penalty
if the user says no.
If they say no, present
rationalization.
Present your value
proposition to them.
If they still say no, let it be.
But the idea is
the first request,
the users that understand
your value prompt,
they get one dialogue.
That's great.
The users that don't,
they'll get a no,
they'll see your
value proposition.
If they still say no, let it be.
AUDIENCE: What happened to
the rest of the permissions?
If I've got an app that
wants to do Wi-Fi scanning,
where'd that one go?
BEN POIESZ: Yeah, so there's a
lot of refactoring that we'll
be doing under the hood.
And soul searching
about permissions.
One of things that
we didn't mention
is, there's
dangerous permissions
and normal permissions.
Everything that's
flagged as normal,
you don't have to worry
about being taken away.
Those are still
automatically granted.
There's no toggle
to turn those off.
Things like Wi-Fi, we're
changing some of the semantics
around how they get requested
and some of the rules
around how you
get Mac addresses.
So one of the more nuanced
items-- I'll mention it now
so you can find
it out later-- is
if you're trying to find out the
Mac address of remote Bluetooth
devices when doing Wi-Fi scans.
Those will come back no unless
you actively hold the location
permission, since typically
remote Mac addresses
for Bluetooth and
Wi-Fi tend to be
about finding and
triangulating your location.
So we've done some restructuring
and behavioral stuff
under the hood.
That's actually somewhat
documented already,
but there will be more
coming out on that.
If you look at developer.com,
the current highlight
on permissions, it
actually mentions
some of that stuff about
Wi-Fi specifically.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
BEN POIESZ: Yup.
AUDIENCE: So I may
have missed it,
but there's no category for
internet-style permission,
right?
BEN POIESZ: Correct.
AUDIENCE: So that
means, by default,
all internet-like permission are
basically allowed to the app?
BEN POIESZ: Yup.
AUDIENCE: So does it mean
you could have a flashlight
application, but [INAUDIBLE]
get [INAUDIBLE] information
and then send data back to--
BEN POIESZ: Yeah, so a
flashlight application
could have internet.
It would then, though, have
to ask for all permissions
to get data off your device.
So the idea is, because
we're preventing access
to the data upfront, it
may have the internet,
but it's not going
to have anything
that we're concerned about.
At least, that a user
should be concerned about.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
AUDIENCE: So did
you consider a model
of sandboxing instead of just
returning null information?
And what is the possibility
of that in the future?
BEN POIESZ: Yeah,
sandboxing is something
we've been looking at for
a few different things,
but it's not something
we're planning on doing,
at least right now.
The idea was to try
to minimize-- sandbox,
you mean like to
provide fake data?
As opposed to--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, fake data.
Or just only certain
data, like if they
wanted to save a contact,
we can let them have access
to that one contact.
BEN POIESZ: You
create a new issue.
Now the application is working
and the data set's disjoint.
And the user really
notices weird behaviors,
where if you're
seeing a null set,
it becomes much more obvious.
So where I go to Calendar
and my Calendar application
shows no calendar entries.
And it's much more obvious
as to what's going on.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Has there
been any thought
of granting an equivalent
of the intent handler
chooser of a just-once?
So grant permission to do the
action I'm doing right now,
but not blanket
permission from now on?
BEN POIESZ: Yeah,
so we're looking
at a number of different
ways that developers can ask
for different types of data.
We're trying to look at them
as-- things that are just once,
things that our user chooses
or things that are more
blanket independent access.
What we're trying to do
is balance user fatigue
on seeing too many.
So at least right
now, we're trying
to avoid the just-once for
these groups of permissions.
But for the intent ones
that you're mentioning,
those are the way we're
structuring just-once,
is fire the intent.
And that's a one-time
picker for it.
But thanks for the comment.
AUDIENCE: Can you clarify about
the Don't ask again option?
So if a user selects that and,
say, in the [? keep app, ?]
they hit the Record
button again.
Do we get a security exception?
Or?
BEN POIESZ: No, you'll
get a fast no from that.
So if a user says,
don't ask me again,
you invoke the
[INAUDIBLE] check.
The OS will respond
very quickly with a no.
You do have the information
to know that the user said
don't ask again.
When the user says, don't ask
again, you're aware of that.
There's a few
different strategies
you can take, depending on
how important feature is.
You might just say, let's
just hide the record button.
You might just say, maybe we
should keep the record button.
If they press it again,
we're back in the game.
But generally you should
consider the Don't ask again
like almost the nuclear option.
We're using it as a
signal of dissonance
between the developer
and the user.
AUDIENCE: And at that
point, if we kept the option
on the screen, we would
present a message saying, hey,
you disabled this permission,
so we can't do this.
Do we have a direct
intent to the settings?
BEN POIESZ: You have
an intent to take them
to the app page for
yourself, but not
to the permissions
page, specifically.
So we did want to make
it a big deal when
the user says, don't ask again.
But you will have recourse.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I have a question
about compatibility.
So will I still be able to
build a single APK targeting
Android M?
And leverage this
new permission model
and have it work
properly on the older
devices that do not support it?
BEN POIESZ: No.
Yes.
I'm not sure anyone would
believe me if I said no.
So yes.
So the structure of it
is, since you're still
declaring the
fine-grained permissions,
the individual
ones-- because those
are being mapped into
the larger groups
that you're seeing-- you don't
really need to do anything
special on older ones.
[? Supportlib ?] has
mainly no functioning
for the different functions when
you're calling check permission
grants and request permissions.
All those things get nulled out.
So you don't have to do
anything special on your code
to deal with older OSs.
You just keep doing what
you're doing, declare ones.
There is one-- it's more
of an advanced feature,
but you're asking about
it-- is, let's say you have
a permission you want to add.
You don't have it today.
You want to add it
only on M devices,
because you don't want to
take the hit on L devices.
And so we have a
Manifest option that you
can define that will
allow you to only ask
for this new permission and
declare it on m devices.
This way, your L devices don't
get impacted by your requests
and requiring you
just to accept.
But you can get the
free flow upfront.
It's a choice.
If you want them
all, go for it--
if you only want it on the
new ones, go for that as well.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
BEN POIESZ: Yup.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
In case of legacy
[? development ?] apps,
would user be allowed to
disable the permissions?
BEN POIESZ: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is there any
way to disable that?
BEN POIESZ: Disable?
Being able to turn
off the permissions?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
BEN POIESZ: In which sense?
By who?
AUDIENCE: For development apps.
BEN POIESZ: For
development apps.
AUDIENCE: Where admin wants
to control their devices.
BEN POIESZ: Oh, I get you.
So in the case of Device
Owner and Profile Owner,
which are the Android
[? Work ?] features
that we have in Android,
there is an ability
to set policies around
the permissions.
Dave mentioned a
coaster device--
it's a corporate-owned
single-use device,
like a kiosk.
You could then say, I want
this application running.
I want its permissions
enforced to these values.
And so, as you're a device
owner in that scenario,
you're able to dictate terms.
Device Owner is
not Device Admin,
it's a different concept.
But that's our
cases where you want
to be able to have
that stricter control.
But in general, we're
pretty sensitive to making
sure users have the
full power of this.
AUDIENCE: So Legacy development
won't have those permissions.
BEN POIESZ: Correct.
Device admin, we're
transitioning that.
So maybe an aside.
But we are transitioning
that to a more
consumer-oriented feature set as
opposed to a corporate feature
set.
With Device Owner and
Profile Owner being the tools
that are better scoped
and have better longevity
than Device Admin.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Does this code have
any kinship to the Apps Ops
feature that was briefly--
BEN POIESZ: I blanked out there.
What was that?
I was waiting for
something to ask.
We learned a lot from App Ops.
I think a lot of the
technical guts of it
are how we implemented the
fallback behavior for L.
But we found, by itself,
without a more holistic re-look
and rethink and re-structure
of how we do permissions,
it didn't make a lot of sense.
But it does have some
underpinnings from that.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: I can
see cases when it
can be really annoying to
the user asking permission
at runtime.
Is there a plan for
still allowing people
to ask permissions all
at once ahead of time?
BEN POIESZ: So it's
something we're looking at
and we're going to
be tracking pretty
closely to see what's going on.
Myself, I'm very
sensitive to that.
The reason is, if we end up
with user fatigue on these,
you end up not actually
helping people.
And so there's this
balance of making sure
that we have enough
prompts but not so many
that the users are
like, I don't care.
Just go away.
So we're going to be
keeping a close eye on that.
At the moment, the
reason-- just to be blunt--
that we structured it where
we let you request many
but then that you can
present them one at a time
is that we have the API for
you to ask for multiple things.
And we have, then, the right,
at some point, to change the UI.
Well, we could say,
OK, we do think
it's more appropriate to show
multiple and one-shot, as
opposed to 101.
The reason we didn't
was many teams
thankfully were
very honest with us
internally about what they
planned to do if that existed.
And we extrapolated to what we
saw around external developers
as to what they would do.
And we felt most applications
would probably just
ask for everything
upfront and then fall back
to asking individually.
And that's arguably worse than
the situation we have today.
So that's the main
reason we didn't do it--
but it is something
we're keeping an eye on.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Similar
to the previous one,
what's happening with
applications that listening
to intents and start services
without any UI, even on app
install?
BEN POIESZ: So applications that
have no UI whatsoever but need
permissions, I don't
really understand those,
just to be honest.
But there are ways
to get something.
If you don't have an appropriate
way to ask for something--
say you're a background
service and it's
hard to present yourself.
One is you can invoke
an activity directly.
You could present a
notification as well.
And the notification could be
a, hey, turn on this permission.
And they click it and you
can invoke these dialogues
from the notification.
So you have some recourse.
But the idea is, even if
you're in the background,
you need to be able to
present your Roi effectively
and your use case to the
user as to why you want
to be given that permission.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So if a user has denied
a permission twice
and they've said,
don't ask me again.
But it turns out that
permission is actually
critical for the
application to function.
You said we should show
some messaging that says,
this is required to turn on.
Will there be an intent
provided that we could actually
take you straight
to the permission
settings for your application?
BEN POIESZ: Yes, so you can
intent directly to Settings
to the top level for it.
If they've said,
don't ask again,
you can only intent to
your application level.
If they haven't said,
don't ask again--
so maybe it's the
second request and they
haven't said that
apocalyptic version,
you intent directly to
your permissions page.
And that's a difference that
we make to try and balance
the user's statement
that they don't
want to be asked any more.
So generally [INAUDIBLE]
that's important to model
is, ask first.
That's cool.
But the second ask, be
pretty sure the user's
on the same page as you
before you ask again.
And that's something like
screeners or, hey, I do this.
Is that OK?
And they're like, yeah.
OK, now prompt.
Consider the second prompt
to be the more-- be careful
about the second prompt, because
they might check the box.
AUDIENCE: So if it's already
been denied and they say,
don't ask again, you cannot
go to the permission settings
page.
But if they haven't--
BEN POIESZ: If they haven't
checked Don't Ask Again,
then you can intent directly
to the permissions page.
If they have, you can't.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
BEN POIESZ: Yup.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Are OEM-installed apps still
subject to the same runtime
permission checks?
BEN POIESZ: That's
a good question.
So yes, they are.
We are working on
some specific policies
to avoid silly situations, like
things where calling doesn't
work and things like that.
But in general, yes.
We do want it to
be a runtime model,
so we do want the
people to be asking.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
BEN POIESZ: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
briefly system intents
that have implied permissions.
My question is specifically
around the Contacts.
When you have the people picker,
it gives you permissions.
It seems, in practice, to
only give you permission
actually to the full name and
the phone number, I believe.
Not the email address
or anything else.
Is there any chance you might
take a look at that again?
BEN POIESZ: Yes, I will
take a look at that again.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: What if
you've included
a library that requires
permissions and then
we compile?
BEN POIESZ: Yes.
You should know what your
libraries are asking for
and need.
Either the library should
be doing requests for you
or letting you know very clearly
what they may be needing.
It can create a strange
situation for the developer
if you're including a library
and it needs a permission
and it starts exploding
because it doesn't
understand the new model.
But you compile them
into the new SDK
but maybe they're not
ready for the new SDK.
So something to be aware of.
I don't have a good fix for you,
other than tell you be aware.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
Do you have any plan to
differentiate between required
versus optional permissions?
BEN POIESZ: No.
AUDIENCE: OK.
BEN POIESZ: I can give you a
bit more of an explanation.
But the idea is we felt
that a lot of folks,
if there was a
required option, we'd
very quickly most things
would be required.
And we felt for applications
where they truly are required,
it should probably
make sense to the user
by the purpose of
the application.
I'll use WhatsApp as an example,
since they were in the keynote.
They, upfront, want to
verify your phone number.
That's how they make
sure that you're
the owner of the
phone number and they
reference all your links.
So if you say no to that,
I expect them to be like,
I don't know what
you want me to do.
So I think there will be
pretty clear cases for apps
to take that behavior, where
they don't need the OS to help
in that enforcement.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
AUDIENCE: So my
question was already
asked about the libraries.
And how concerned are
you with the behavior
that's going to be breaking with
old libraries and everything?
And also the problem
that is going
to be created with
analytics providers,
because they require a lot of--
BEN POIESZ: They do.
AUDIENCE: Dependencies
that we don't know about.
That's something to
be concerned about.
BEN POIESZ: Yeah, so
Lint is going to flag it.
So at least you should
be able to know.
If you look at Lint
it will let you know.
AUDIENCE: It'll be
some [INAUDIBLE].
So change my question, then.
You talked about
a support library
that was going with
backwards compatibility.
What are you throwing in there?
BEN POIESZ: Huh?
AUDIENCE: What are
you putting in there?
BEN POIESZ: What is it?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
BEN POIESZ: It's
essentially if you're
calling the new code
in your application.
That's how I'm targeting API 23.
We want to make
sure that you're not
going to explode when
you're running on other OSs
if you happen to run that code.
AUDIENCE: So the
[? method ?] checks
are going to be in the
support libraries, right?
BEN POIESZ: No, there's versions
of them in the support library
for older OSs, but it's in the
proper SDK, the [? OS-SDK. ?]
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
AUDIENCE: I saw
that Android M has
a new auto-update
capability as well.
Do you know if permissions
will be carried over
as part of this in addition?
BEN POIESZ: Auto-update?
AUDIENCE: So if I were
to uninstall, reinstall,
I would have all of the previous
data synced up to Google Drive?
BEN POIESZ: Yeah.
Permissions is not
a part of that.
When the application's
uninstalled,
we will start anew as
if it's a new situation.
AUDIENCE: OK.
BEN POIESZ: All right.
Thank you all